will the deal that resolves the shutdown
include any form of amnesty for people
here illegally now
well our focus is on border security
well of course but the democrats focus
is on focus getting amnesty for people
here illegally
will you agree to that what we've
completely focused on is keeping the
president's promise
to build a wall to pass legislation that
provides other support
for border security that gives the
people that are enforcing our laws at
the border
and across the country enforcing our
immigration laws the resources and the
tools
that they need there's a lot of people
talking about a lot of different ideas
you know
frankly the better part of a year ago
the president expressed a willingness
to deal with the issue of dreamers in a
compassionate way for
people who were brought here as children
through no fault of their own
he's discussed that it's being talked
about but
here's the posture the president ever
since ever since the christmas holiday
the president sent us to capitol hill i
met with senator schumer not once but
twice
we engaged in good faith negotiations
the president and i cancelled all of our
christmas vacation plans we were here in
washington d.c
democrats broke off negotiations about a
week ago but the president's made it
clear
we're here to make a deal but it's a
deal that's going to result
in achieving real gains on border
security
and you have no border security without
a wall
we will have no deal without a wall
if the deal in the end includes
allowing people who came here as adults
intentionally to break our laws to
become
citizens then wouldn't the message to
the rest of us be why should we obey the
law if people who intentionally broke it
are being rewarded for it can you see
why that would be
a perverse incentive for the rest of us
i absolutely can and i've heard no
discussion of that i've heard no
discussion of
okay amnesty related to this i heard
some members of the senate are talking
about maybe including dreamers in some
sort of a negotiated settlement right
and the president's posture on all this
is look we're at 5.6 billion
we have engaged in good faith
negotiations we've made offers there's
been
no counter offers made but again we we
heard the democrat leadership the new
speaker of the house this morning again
said
no money for the wall well the american
people know walls work
and we heard from border agents today in
the oval office that
that in areas in sectors where they were
assigned
to deal with illegal immigration the
flow of narcotics human trafficking all
the
all the threats to our communities that
we face
at our border that once they built a
wall you saw illegal immigration the
flow of narcotics dropped
precipitously so the bottom line is you
will not accept a deal that does not
include a wall
if i'm hearing this right i think the
president's made made it very clear yes
there's no wall no deal
and but look we really are prepared
to negotiate we're prepared to talk
we're prepared to listen and
and ultimately it all begins with the
facts i mean that's the reason why the
president called the meeting in the
situation room we'll be meeting again
tomorrow with republican and democrat
leadership and i want the
american people to know that that you
know this is a real crisis at our border
we made progress last year
and it probably was a result of the fact
that the american people elected
a new president who delivered a very
strong
message about confronting illegal
immigration we actually saw a decline in
illegal immigration and incursions on
our southern border
but in the last 12 months we've
literally seen a dramatic increase
in the number of people 2 000 people a
day
apprehended at our border or found to be
inadmissible trying to enter
our country i mean that represents
as much as we were all troubled in
recent weeks about the caravans moving
north and there's talks about more
caravans
literally 2 000 people a day attempt to
come into this country illegally by one
means or another
we can agree on those facts come
together around solutions
but part of that solution means a wall
it means a barrier
in in along our southern border right
and it also means
technology drones the kind of support
that our border agents know will assist
them in doing their job
but but bottom line if there's no wall
there's no deal
the president uh the other day announced
the withdrawal of the 2000 american
troops
in syria back to the united states
nobody in washington like that including
some republicans lindsey graham said
probably not going to happen there was a
pause on that withdrawal what is the
state of that are those troops coming
home and if so when
you know president trump as
commander-in-chief
and as a candidate made it clear that
our our number one priority would be
destroying isis the reality is we have
defeated
isis we have defeated the caliphate and
what the president announced just before
christmas is not that we're giving up on
the fight on isis we're going to
continue to lean into the fight of isis
we're going to continue to
take the actions that are necessary to
protect the american people and our
interests in the region
but the president is determined in
consultation with military commanders
including an al-assad
air force base when he was there just
after christmas that it's no longer
necessary
for us to have american forces in harm's
way
in northeastern syria to accomplish that
do you think we can expect in the next
few months those troops to come back
well i think the president's made it
clear we're going to do this and are
doing this
in an orderly way i heard him in
dozens and dozens of speeches talk about
bringing our troops home wherever we
could
around the world this is not a president
they accomplished they accomplished the
tasks what about afghanistan i'm
defeating the caliphate
right now we can bring them out of syria
do you think that we're winning the
conflict in afghanistan do you think the
united states benefits from the
continued presence of
such a large number of u.s troops there
well the president is in the process of
evaluating that
as we speak i was in afghanistan last
year
in his speech in august president trump
basically through new rules of
engagement new resources additional
military personnel
gave our folks on the ground the ability
to take the fight
and be at the tip of the spear
supporting the afghan national army
in the battle against the taliban isis
corazon
uh al-qaeda really working in
afghanistan
and it's been a tough fight i mean the
president's been very clear about that
and now i think the president's in the
process of evaluating options about
what has been as you know tucker we've
both lived through it in the last two
decades what has been a
an 18-year conflict in afghanistan and
determining what our best options are
in terms of putting america first
protecting america's interests
in the region making sure that we can
confront terrorism right if it if it
rears its head once again but
the president's looking at ways in syria
and perhaps even in afghanistan where we
can have less of a military commitment
and see those resources and those troops
coming home mr vice president thank you
thank you appreciate it good to be with
you